the aftermath of clashes between Kurdish
forces and Isis near Kirkuk the Islamic
militants want control of the oil-rich
city but unlike the Iraqi army the Kurds
are not backing down they have long
fought for an independent state in this
region and are putting up the only
credible resistance in the north of Iraq
it's to these regions that hundreds of
thousands of people are fleeing
displaced by the Islamist advance while
the Kurds have stopped the insurgents
drive towards care cook the Sunni
militants claim they have now gained
control of the country's largest oil
refinery in bargy heavy fighting has
continued throughout the day oil
production here has stopped but Iraq's
Prime Minister remains optimistic a lot
more Hardison Iraq is a unified country
consisting of Sunnis Shiites Arabs and
Kurds we have a common challenge to
fight the terrorists from al Qaeda dr
aamir hardy here is our little no but
this kind of talkers failed to convince
neighboring Iran president Hassan
rouhani has vowed to do whatever it
takes to protect Shiite holy sites in
Iraq against the Sunni militants
including dispatching militias to Iraq
volunteers are also lining up in Baghdad
to fight the ISIS extremists and heavily
armed soldiers are patrolling the
streets a show of strength at least in
the capital